يؤدي الى فقدان الذاكره وببطء التنفس
وانخفاض معدل ضربات القلب وضغط الدم لكن
جميع هذه الاعراض المميته لم ترضع مدمنيه
عن تعاطي فماذا نعرف عن هذا القاتل الذي
يتوافد عليه ضحاياه بمخض ارادتهم مخدر
جديد ينتشر بسرعه كبيره في العديد من
الولايات الامريكيه يعتمد في تكوينه على
عقار يسمى الزلازين وهو مهدئ غير افيوني
يستخدم في الطب البيطري وغير معتمد
للاستخدام البشريه لكن مدمنه من البشر
يخلطونه مع الكوكايين والهيروين والعديد
من انواع المخدرات اما عن تسميته بمخدر
الزومبي فكانت لانه يسبب تقرحاتا وعفونه
في الجلد ما يؤدي في نهايه المطاف الى بتر
اطراف متعاطين اذا لم يتم علاجها يعرف
المخدر ايضا باسم ولحظ انتشاره في معظم
الولايات الامريكيه بحسب تصريحات لاداره
مكافحه المخدرات الامريكيه ويمكن عن طريق
الشم او الحقن او التدخين بيانات اداره
مكافحه المخدرات اظهرت ارتفاع اعداد وفيات
الجرعات الزائده من الزنانين في جميع
مناطق الولايه المتحده من عام 2020 الى
عام 2021 وللحد من انتشار المخدر قالت
اداره الغذاء والدواء الامريكيه انها
ستقيد والده الزلازين وكذلك المكونات
المستخدمه في صناعتها للتاكد من انها
ستخصص لاستخدام الحيواني المشروع